la parole est au président Jean-Claude
Gaudin pour le groupe
UMP enfin une respiration
démocratique monsieur monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre chers
collègues rapporteur madame la
Présidente nous sommes ravis monsieur le
ministre de vous retrouver à nouveau sur
ces ban nous sommes un peu gênés pour
vous et votre emploi du temp que votre
gouvernement vous envoie semaine après
semaine défendre des réformes
électorales dont personne ne veut
réellement même y compris au sein de
votre propre majorité ne croyez-vous pas
que nous soyons l'ASSÉ de ces
rendez-vous quasi hebdomadaires avec
vous mais les sujets dont nous avons à
débattre sont vraiment répétitif en 1 an
nous avons eu droit au changement de
seuil pour la proportionnelle élections
municipales à la modification des règles
d'élection des conseillers
intercommunaux à la suppression des
conseillers territoriaux au
rétablissement de la proportionnelle
pour les conseillers régionaux à la
création baroque et sans équivalent au
monde de binom de conseillers
départementaux si à moi sur de très
grand canton j'ajouterai qu'il fallait
beaucoup d'audace pour présenter au
Parlement un projet de loi
sexualisant les candidatures aux
élections cantonales au moment même où
vous soumettiez dans un texte
dexualisant le mariage mais là c'était
avant à l'initiative de votre majorité
l'Assemblée nationale a également eu à
débattre du changement de mode de
scrutin pour les élections européenne et
n'en doutons pas sous peu vous
reviendrez nous voir avec la proportionn
pour les élections
législatives cet inventaire me fait
penser à Marcel Pagnol qui dans la
Gloire de mon père se souvenait des
vieilleries que son père ramoné des
brocanteur après avoir touché son mandat
à la mairie il écrivait un compat
diviseur et pointé un franc 50 une scie
de chirurgien de francs une long vue à
Marie nous l'envoyé tout à l'envers 3
francs un couteau à scalp 2 francs si
Marcel Pagnol ne savait pas ce que son
père pouvait faire d'une SCI de
chirurgien et d'un couteau à scalp nous
monsieur le ministre nous n'avons aucun
doute sur l'usage que vous en
ferez nous avons
plaisir nous avons plaisir à vous voir
Monsieur le Ministre mais quitte à vous
voir toutes les semaines ne
pourrions-nous pas plutôt discuter des
sujets qui relèvent de votre
responsabilité et sur lesquels nos
concitoyens expriment des inquiétudes de
plus en plus fortes il y a dans nos
quartiers et pas seulement dans les
quartiers des français qui n'ont pas la
même échelle de priorité que le
gouvernement auquel vous appartenez il y
a des Français qui ont du mal à
percevoir l'urgence nationale qu'il y a
à légiférer pour offrir aux élus
socialistes des modes de scrutin sur
mesure pour contourner l'inévitable
sanction des urnes c'est français
monsieur le ministre comment voulez-vous
qu'ils admettent que l'imagination de
vos services a été dévolue à changer les
modes de scrutin plutôt qu'à trouver des
solutions à la délinquance qui a repris
de plus Bell il est vrai que
l'imagination de votre gouvernement est
sans borne en matière électorale pendant
les élections votre c'est l'imagination
au pouvoir une fois élu ce serait plutôt
l'imagination pour garder le pouvoir
nous aurions aimé autant d'imagination
pour lutter en faveur de l'emploi
malheureusement une fois rangé l'assis
de chirurgie et le couteau à scalper il
n'y a plus de place dans votre fameuse
boîte à outi pour d'autres ustensiles
mais il est vrai monsieur le ministre
qu'en matière d'inventivité électorale
vous avez de glorieux prédécesseurs
place beau vous je pense notamment au
prédécesseurs que nous avons eu en
commun monsieur Gaston de fer quelle
injuniosité c'est l'homme qui a inventé
le PLM dont l'originalité a été de
séparer les arrondissements parisiens
pour que les conseillers de Paris soient
élus dans chacun des 20 arrondissements
et dans le même temps
de regrouper par quatre par trois par
deux quelquefois un seul les
arrondissements marseillais sans aucune
logique territoriale afin de noyer les
îos de droite dans des secteurs de gosse
il a fallu attendre 2001 pour que la loi
de fer profite aux socialistes à Paris
en effet avec moins de 49 % des
suffrages Bertrand alanoué a été élu
maire de Paris grâce à cette incongruité
électorale avec moins de voix que la
droite la gauche a obtenu 21 sièges
d'avance au Conseil de Paris alors je
vous rassure tout de suite en revanche à
Marseille Gaston de fer on n'a pas eu à
attendre 20 ans les bénéfices de cette
enterloupe électorale grâce au scrutin
de secteur il sera réélu en 1900 c'est
l'histoire en
1983 bien que votre serviteur à l'époque
est obtenu 2500 voix de plus que lui
mais rassurez-vous tout avait été bien
pensé dans les secteurs de gauche le
nombre des élus était impèire comme ça
on pouvait arrondir à l'entier supérieur
plus un siège et dans les secteur de
droite le nombre des élus était pair et
ben comme ça on on arrondissait que dal
à l'entier supérieur j'ai vécu cette
période monsieur Kaltenbach ça
m'autorise à faire un rappel mais cette
parenthèse close nous voici donc à
nouveau réunis avec vous monsieur le
ministre le dépussage des cantons n'est
pas terminé nous le savons mais
l'écarissage du Sénat va débuter il est
vrai que le Sénat de la République est
le trublionon quotidien de votre
majorité depuis 1 an il ne pouvait pas
plus braver le gouvernement plus
longtemps sans encourir la sanction le
Sénat enfin de gauche symbolise à vos
lieux en 2011 de l'irrésistible marche
vers le pouvoir du Parti socialiste qui
se retrouve finalement aujourd'hui votre
premier opposant tous les textes
importants sont rejetés les uns après
les autres loi des finances loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale loi
énergie conseillers départementaux plus
rarement certains textes du gouvernement
sont adoptés et encore le sont-ils parce
que le groupe UMP est venu à votre
secours comme la loi de lutte contre le
terrorisme ou votre propre majorité vous
faisz une fois de plus défaut finalement
vous constaterez avec moi qu'il faut que
les textes viennent de l'opposition pour
qu'il soit adopté à l'unanimité par le
Sénat je pense au référendum
d'initiative partagée ou à notre
résolution consacrant les droits et
libertés des collectivités territoriales
il fallait donc punir le Sénat et pour
cela vous avez fait appel au plusur IR
réductibles adversairirees de la Haute
Assemblée sur la 5e République Monsieur
Lionel Jospin Lionel Jospin n'a jamais
admis qu'une assemblée de la République
puisse représenter les territoires seul
la stricte démographie comptaéit à ses
yeux 14 ans après
avoir qualifié d'anomalie démocratique
cela a été rappelé tout à l'heure
l'ancien Premier ministre poursuit son
archargement contre le Sénat et la
ruralité en 2000 sa réforme du Sénat qui
visait à affaiblir la représentation des
communes rurales avait été censuré cela
a été dit aussi par le Conseil
constitutionnel mais car cela ne tienne
avec la même obsession il reformule à
l'automne les mêmes propositions au nom
d'une commission composée d'aucun
d'aucun nélu la proportionnelle à partir
de trois sièges et l'affaiblissement du
poids des communes rurales dans le
collège électoral sénatorial en
augmentant celui des départements et des
régions c'est ce qu'il proposait à
rebour de tous les principes
constitutionnels Lionel jobpin va
jusqu'à proposer le vote plural de quoi
s'agit-il il s'agit tout simplement de
donner des bulletins de vote de
différentes valeurs comme des jetons de
casino aux grands électeurs afin
d'écraser la représentation de la
ruralité ici tel maire rural aura une
voix et là tel conseiller régional en
aura 15 dieu merci il n'y a pas eu un
constitutionnaliste sérieux pour aller
dans ce sens vous avez donc dû
privilégier d'autres pistes pour
façonner un peu le le Sénat à votre main
ce fut l'extension de la proportionnelle
à partir de trois sièges quel impérative
vous a-t-il animé la
parité le pluralisme si tel était le cas
vous auriez également préconisé ce
système pour les cantonnales or pour les
cantonnales vous avez justement
privilégié une variante du mode de
scrutin sénatorial actuel poursuivons si
vous êtes réellement convaincu que ce
mode de scrutin est le plus juste pour
le Sénat alors pourquoi n'êtes-vous pas
allé jusqu'à descendre la
proportionnelle au département etlisant
de deux sénateurs on en a parlé pourquoi
vous arrêtez-vous à trois sièges tout
simplement pour gagner pour gagner sur
le tapis vert un scrutin qui s'annonce
d'ors et déjà difficile dans les urnes
la proportionnelle à partir de de sièg
aurait défavorisé le Parti socialiste
c'est pour ça que vous n'en voulez pas
ce car c'est dans cette strate de
département que vous réalisez vos
meilleurs résultats faut-il que je cite
les 15 départements où la majorité euh
aurait tout à y perdre alors ou puis-je
m'arrêter simplement pour citer tiens la
corise dans ces départements je doute
fort que vos élus auraient accepté comme
cela a été dit d'offrir l'un des deux
sièges à l'opposition dans ces
départements le pluralisme et la parité
deviennent curieusement des objectifs
moins immédiats en revanche examinons
les départements etlis en tris sénateurs
25 départements seront concernés parce
que par ce basculement vers la
proportionnelle don 17 départements dès
2014 or ce sont prép principalement des
sénateurs de l'opposition qui seront
impactés en effet sur les 51 sénateurs
sortant concernés on dénombre 27 UMP 7
udi et un non inscrit c'est-à-dire 35
sénateurs de l'opposition pour 16
sénateurs seulement de la majorité ainsi
sur la série renouvelable en 2014 à
collège électoral constant la gauche
gagnerait mécaniquement neu sièges et
n'en perdra que deux plus se sièges pour
la majorité moins se sièges pour
l'opposition cela signifie donc outre
ces six sièges de retard actuel
l'opposition entamera ces sénatoriales
avec un handicap mécanique de 14 sièges
supplémentair avec la proportionnelle à
partir de trois sièges la majorité
sénatoriale soffre donc une marge de 20
sièges il faut quand même qu'on vous le
dise ne croyez pas que ça nous pas
inaperçu alors monsieur le ministre il
n'y a aucune raison d'abaisser la
proportionnelle à partir de trois sièges
ce seuil n'a aucun sens et je vouis vous
emporter la preuve jusqu'au
renouvellement de 98 la proportionnelle
ne s'appliquait qu'à partir de 5 sièges
1/ers des sièges était donc renouvelés à
la proportionnelle la loi Jospin de 2000
a abaissé le seuil de la proportionnelle
à partir de trois sièges seule la série
B de 2001 ut renouvelé selon cette règle
le rapport fut alors inversé 3/4 des
sièges furent donc renouvelés à la
proportionnelle revenu au pouvoir en
2002 notre majorité aurait pu rétablir
la proportionnelle à partir de C sièges
nous n'avons pas souhaité le faire car
il nous semblait qu'il fallait arrêter
cette bataille de mode de scrutin nous
avions donc proposé une loi de compromis
qui devait nous permettre ettre de nous
retrouver à mi-chemin des aspirations
des deux camps en fixant le seuil de la
proportionnelle à quatre sièges nous
avons atteint un juste équilibre puisque
la moitié des sénateurs sont élus à la
proportionnelle 52 % et l'autre moitié
au scrutin majoritaire 48 %. ce
compromis s'est appliqué au
renouvellement de 2004 de 2008 de 2011
ce seuil avait voocation à durée vous
voulez aujourd'hui le
sur l'hôtel de vos intérêts l'autre
mesure de votre projet de loi est tout
aussi insidieuse il s'agit de
l'augmentation du nombre de délégués
dans les communes de plus de 30000
habitants la tentation de la gauche a
toujours été de restreindre la part des
communes rurales dans le collège
électoral sénatorial la loi Jospin de
2000 censuré par le Conseil
constitutionnel proposé déjà une
représentation purement démographique
des communes chaque commune aurait
désigné un grand électeur par tranche de
300 habitants ce système ubuesque aurait
conduit à faire élire les sénateurs par
un collège électoral mes chers collègues
majoritairement composé de délégués non
élus jusqu'à
71 % du corps électoral dans certains
départements d'île-de France la décision
du Conseil constitutionnel c'était avé
protectrice pour la représentation de la
ruralité puisqu'elle a affirmé cela a
été dit tout à l'heure que le Sénat
devait rester élu par un corps électoral
essentiellement composé des membres des
assemblées délibérantes et des
collectivité
territoriale c'est cette décision que
vous essayez de contourner aujourd'hui
en proposant qu'un délégué
supplémentaire soit désigné par tranche
de 800 habitants dans les communes de
plus de 30000 habitants en vous me
l'avez dit tout à l'heure que premier
bénéficiaire monsieur Kaltenbach le
maire de Marseille ne devrait pas s'en
plaindre oui sauf qu'il faudra compter
aussi les élus du Front national mais
cela me donne au contraire plus de force
pour vous dire que cette règle est
injuste et pénalisante pour nos
territoires ruraux en procédant ainsi
vous augmentez le collège électoral
sénatorial de plus de 3000 délégués
supplémentaires au bénéfice des 260
communes les plus peuplées dans la
situation d'équilibre politique que
connaît le Sénat aujourd'hui je vous dis
solennellement qu'il me semble hasardeux
de modifier cette règle de compromis
sans risquer d'entacher la sincérité du
prochain scrutin sénatorial le texte que
vous proposez a été rejeté par la
commission des lois de notre haute
assemblée passer en force ne serait pas
acceptable sur l'élection des
conseillers départementaux il était
choquant que le gouvernement donne le
dernier mot à l'Assemblée nationale sur
un texte relatif aux collectivités
territoriales alors que le Sénat l'avait
rejeté mais passer en force à
l'Assemblée national un projet de loi
relatif au Sénat contre la vie du Sénat
serait encore plus grave alors avant de
conclure monsieur le ministre je
voudrais faire appel au sens du dialogue
qui a su être le vôtre dans de
nombreuses circonstan jusqu'à présent
monsieur notre collègue éminent Yve
d'regne vous l'a dit tout à l'heure
prendrez-vous l'engagement de stopper la
navette si le Sénat rejette ce texte en
première lecture comme il l'a fait en
commission enfin monsieur le ministre en
persistant à passer ce projet de loi
vous ne vous rendez pas service vous le
savez les électeurs sanctionnent
toujours durement ce qui manipule les
modes de scrutin
vous avez fait la Mure expérience dans
le passé nous aussi nous aussi par
ailleurs
àf en y réfléchissant bien vous ne
servez pas vos intérêts en tentant de
maintenir coûte que coûte et contre le
sens du courant le Sénat à gauche votre
gouvernement est battu sur tous les
textes par sa propre majorité sous le
regard attentif de la presse qui ne
manque pas de souligner les échecs que
le Sénat vous inflige vous vous rendriez
service à laisser le Sénat revenir à
droite et au centre bien entendu les
textes continueraient d'être rejetés
avec le même entraint mais vous pourriez
vous retrancher derrière le fait que le
Sénat et dorénamant dans l'opposition
alors si vous ne le faites pas par souci
d'équité électorale faites-le pour
vous-même renoncez à ce projet de loi au
nom de la solidarité
gouvernementale qui existe vraiment et
donc qu'on a entendu encore tout à
l'heure pour simplifier la vie de nos
cègues au Parlement monsieur le ministre
de l'Intérieur les
sénatrices et sénateurs du groupe de
l'UMP ne sont pas du tout favorables à
ce changement du mode de scrutin ils
seront unanimes pour vous le
dire